Russian tanks rolling across the border
in southern Ukraine
airstrikes hitting large cities and
thousands of people attempting to flee
the Ukrainian Capital Kiev footage from
Ukraine shows scenes of war after
President Putin announced a military
operation in the country
everyone here is shocked
everyone here knew that this might be
coming for months it was predicted and
discussed and now that it's here it's
very hard to Fathom and people hear a
lot of them have fled but a lot remain
Ukrainian officials said strike's
targeted military installations
airfields and government facilities
across the country
air raid sirens blared in Kev after
President Putin's statement was
broadcast
Ed
yourself
in the early hours of February 24th
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
declared martial law and quote for
Global assistance
Biden called the move unjustified
pledging new actions against Russia
the EU said it would hit moscow's
financial sector freezing assets and
banning the export of technology to the
country we will weaken Russia's economic
base
and its capacity to modernize
the United Nations condemned Russia's
moves during a meeting of the security
Council late Wednesday
this is
the saddest moment
in my channel
the Secretary General of the United
Nations President Putin in the name of
humanity bring your troops back to
Russia President Vladimir Putin of
Russia said his goal is to hold
Ukraine's leaders to account and and put
them on trial for the last eight years
of events in in danbas we don't know the
end game as yet but as troops enter from
various directions and as airstrikes
continue in all over the country it does
seem possible that Russia's goal is to
make its way to Kiev the capital in
order to take over Ukraine
[Music]